haptic feedback can help people who are
unable to move their limbs to be able to
control things from computer cursors to
prosthetic limbs just by thought alone
so I like to frame it as imagine an als
patient there's this loss of physical
agency that takes place where you are
not capable of actually moving your
limbs and so you don't have a good idea
of where I guess your virtual limb is in
space and can we use haptic technology
to give you a better idea of where your
virtual limb is in space this thing that
I'm putting on my head right now is a
surface EEG headset and basically what
that means is that there are these
various electrodes placed all over my
head and they're capable of measuring
cortical activity and then you can
actually take these signals and a
decoding algorithm can then transform
them into some sort of a command signal
that you can use to command a peripheral
device such as a cursor or a robotic
limb for instance as I am controlling
the cursor on the screen I would get
skin stretch feedback on my fingertip
that's mapped to either the position of
that cursor in space or the velocity at
which it's moving so this takter here
basically comes into contact with your
finger pad and it provides tangential
forces you to this its large density of
mechanoreceptors they're really attuned
to this kind of haptic stimulus and so
you can actually display a direction and
a magnitude of force on the fingertip
and this is kind of a cue you know as to
hey the position of your cursor is up
towards the right of the screen and you
will actually feel then a force that's
kind of pushing your finger
to the right of the screen and so
without them actually being able to move
their finger we can kind of play back
what they would feel if they were able
to do so and we're hoping that that
gives them I guess more intuitive
information as to how they're
controlling this virtual device
you
you